this video is brought to you by manscape
comm manscape is the only brand
dedicated to men's below the waist
grooming and hygiene and they recently
launched a new product the weed whacker
electric nose and ear hair trimmer so
when you don't trim your nose hairs I
don't know about you guys but for me I
grow this really thick long one and then
it starts ticularly all over and so
sometimes I'm just talking to Gio and
I'm just going like this the whole time
and she's like what the hell's wrong
with you and I take allergy medicines I
think it's allergies but it's not it's
just a long nose here with this thing
you can trim it and they'll cut it all
up so you don't have your nose hairs
tickling the inside of your nose keeps
it nice and fresh they don't make funny
faces and you don't have to take allergy
medicine when you don't even need it to
help guys like us back our weeds
manscaped spent over a year developing
the weed whacker electric nose and ear
hair trimmer it's the only ear and nose
trimmer
that's cordless and rechargeable with
the lithium ion battery that lasts up to
90 minutes it also has this proprietary
skin-safe technology that helps prevent
nicks snags and tugs it's also water
resistant so it's good for a wet cutting
and dry cutting medium cutting just
don't go full submerged cutting and we
encourage you guys to check out the new
man ski performance package bundle which
includes a weed whacker and all these
other tools that helps with the mends
below the waist hygiene and grooming
including the lawn mower 3.0 full body
trimmer if you use the code
JK news you can get 20% off and free
shipping from the UK canada's
australia's and the US and we have the
link in the description below thank you
to manscape for keeping our pubes
trimmed and our nose free of weeds
[Music]
so Hollywood productions have been shut
down since March have you guys heard
though that they're gonna be having
these new regulations once they come in
especially when it comes to like sex
scenes they're saying that because of
like the whole social distancing and
stuff that a lot of sex scenes will need
to be rethought possibly cut out or if
they're still gonna go through they're
probably gonna be doing CGI what are
they talking they do POV where I like
the person's on top and it's like you
just see them and they does the
cameraman he just goes like this or they
could just shoot it in Florida
everything flies in Florida that's true
because it depends on the laws in the
state right so they could just go some
state with makeup I should have
straight-up hortal in Florida what the
[__] I need my sex scenes I'm gonna
watch the [__] movie that's not
relatable what there's out those sex
scenes
what's porn gonna do you get a jerk-off
across the room but that's non-union is
it yeah I think I don't think they're
sag actors and those porns probably not
sag but they probably have their own
version oh I pad or something there's a
lot of user submissions too from what
I'm told
you know people people who consume the
porns yeah they tell me that one of the
categories is you heard yeah you know
the porn vine
you know the people like oh this is my
porn and then they just upload it to the
porn websites hey magic horns out like a
mixtape new board job don't beat
subscribe my friends you're as important
you dude that was just the same all
right anal 56
it's amateur it's gotta start with yeah
not even seven to six she wanted to do
the anal they're like please let me do
it the best things is the directors who
are like I want to do a higher quality
[__] like with better cameras and
sound guys it's just like what do an
insert of it but yeah so they're saying
that crew members all crew members will
be required to wear masks visors and
other PPE and they will also be
instructed to frequently wash their
hands and all these rules will be
enforced by coronavirus compliance
officer oh [__] off be on set at all
times
really wait with what rules they like
most recent rules or the ones from two
weeks ago they said like you had the
most update you're gonna keep them yeah
Bob Davis so this is a TSA for
coronavirus I hate or like productions
so you're gonna have the product the
producers gonna have to pay for the
compliance army so you not just match up
a set medic can do it medics already
there why can't they do it maybe having
the actors in mess because that's gonna
influence people to not wear masks where
they're having sex and I might could
cause more a corona virus spreads that
the CGI the mask over but yeah so
they're just saying that they will in
California governor has said that
starting tomorrow
California students at studios can
reopen oh really
gyms baby grand opening are you guys
switching it up like 25 minutes we have
to what is it you just breading the
equipment of car yeah so we did
everything six feet apart and then it's
gonna be reservation only we have to cap
it at like 35 people an hour like the
perk like 35 purse I mean like usually
um it's a relic of that much so it kind
of works out um and then it has to be
reservation only and we are gonna do it
in like two hours that
the reservation only to make sure that
its cat yeah exactly well and while that
and we're gonna we're gonna stop and
then we're gonna clean everything for
like an hour no people there just that
24-hour Fitness is door yeah and then we
open it back up and that's another a lot
of spot people yes they are but it would
be our staff the staff has to spot you
yeah that's the culture anyways take art
like everyone's a lifter everyone spot
each other I guess it's pretty fun dads
are we wearing masks the whole time yeah
yeah hard to work out what a man the
people working out don't need the masks
but our staff will be the best okay got
it got it got it
look he was like happy to Jennifer
clothes because I was like can I have a
solid excuse but usually it's just like
ah it's far it's like restaurants are
open gyms are closed yeah I bought a
treadmill so I couldn't give myself that
excuse did you use it yeah I did but
then I got addicted to animal crossing
you've actually started using it in like
playing animal crossing all the
treadmills I have used it every day the
treadmill love the trouble yeah I've
been walking for an hour and a half
every day oh that's good or six days a
week but then I just go and eat it
pretend like you don't like Fitness you
know what it's a love-hate relationship
that's mostly the poly barn on Instagram
does not help if you're not strong and
stuff he's like Oh jump in the pool swim
swim jump out catch a tiger it's like
hard off the camera nobody even said
anything that's the way you looked at
his picture that's the way the way we've
liked this picture and commented hey
great that was great
you can tell you mean squatting like
super hard with nobody behind you like
what if it's too heavy
I'm not anywhere close to like oh you
just don't call them weak nice like flex
but okay I have an orthodontists
appointment coming up and they told me
like their procedures changed also where
so Isaac and I go to the same worth of
Donna so first he has his
and when we're in the parking lot we
have to call and tell them that we're
there and then they're gonna let us know
when we come in and then once Isaac goes
to his appointment I have to go wait in
the in the car like there's no more
waiting room anymore
oh snap really yeah and then they're
gonna think you don't have a car what if
you weren't there yeah yeah I so I'm
really excited about additions finally
changing on the west coast because
they've already implemented itself tapes
like before the pandemic everywhere else
and the one [__] sucky part of acting
is driving to the audition being in the
waiting room being around a bunch of
nervous ass boys that are [__] and
try to get in your head and stuff self
tapes are so dope I hate audition me too
first I don't look anything same tape
that was us everything that books has
been self - yeah tip enough to be in the
scene and like be there rather than like
being rushed in and out and like people
are stressed and like people are around
you and like somebody who thinks you're
like okay um we really want to see you
then you go in there's like six other
dudes who look just like you guys in LA
that you like I already got this job but
yes Dylan is and all your enemies in
there so it's bad energy and I wouldn't
have believed them before but then it
happened to me where I got it been done
where they still had to do the audition
and like I was looking around be like
it's true oh yeah it's it's for sure
true a lot of times you do the auditions
for the network and all this other stuff
but the person who directed already has
the person but the person and I just
have to have the appearance of
inclusivity do you think they do all
that because it's kind of like something
you up like oh this is part of the
industry just got a deal I think people
just don't care about your feelings yeah
I didn't even call you back and tell you
didn't get it no I like your manager has
to check and sometimes they're just like
yeah they just weren't good enough damn
it's a terrible industry to be a part of
my youtube channel right you can't tell
me I suck
and then the commoner is like you suck
and I'm like
way more people to the officer it's
automatic feedback of how much you suck
thumbs up thumbs down thumbs up on them
I thought you were cool in your last
video but now I don't
oh I just came here gonna tell you you
suck you block me on YouTube so I just
came over here I know you have a lot of
cool platforms for me to tell you so
happens for real
I had a troll itit's troll hope he
doesn't watch this video but he trolled
me right and I have my DM say where if I
don't follow you I won't see it I got
the purpose they go right so that like
clears out a lot of unnecessary people
so he D is my wife who checks otter
falls cause she has smaller followers
she wants to build a community so I had
my niece has an Instagram because my
wife ignored him so she goes with my two
years old I got made her Instagram - I
just heard Instagram so I can like yeah
but you got the DNA of so much time what
was this story about thinking here sex
scenes in Hollywood are CGI sex scenes
in Hollywood to prevent coronavirus
transmissions which makes me think like
if Hollywood's gonna be changing
drastically and having all these like
you know these guidelines that they be
to follow I wonder like how much that's
gonna bleed into every other industry or
like us for example like we're sitting
here not social distancing not worry
this should be done on Zoom oh that's
horrible [__] hate dynamic
that was totally sarcasm she didn't come
across clear face no no by the way I'm
gonna tell you no I'm gonna tell you
what changes I shot us I shot a
webseries myself via zoom no no so I had
the director on Zoom and I had my phone
Wow
I had my phone on a tripod and we would
like do it take and then I would turn
around and show it to the director yes
you always the works cuz now not only
are the actor you're the actor you're
the DP you're the director you you don't
have a you don't remember how many times
you get to take breaks when they like
change the lighting yeah the actors get
to sit down but now you are changing the
lighting and you don't even know how to
change lighting you have to look up a
tutorial it was it was it was so long
man it was like a super short thing but
when you're doing all the work yeah it
was so long I was the worst but I feel
like it's kind of amazing how quickly we
change though like first my audience
hated zoom like just the quality and
interaction which I do agree and then
sound quality sucks but we have nothing
else who are like won't shoot it ain't
that bad
yeah it's like reality TV it's like I
first I was like this sucks and I'm like
oh man we've meet my wife is like
there's so much written marry married at
first sight 90-day fiance Beyonce love
is blind blah blah blah we watched all a
circle of I 11 circle loved Island Laval
in UK wears a Jeopardy last night oh I
love Jeopardy I loved it pre reality
chanel I'm out of weight jeopardy
reality show don't know what's wrong
with your finish out so long okay I
thought it'd change okay you're just
saying okay I'll just say like how far
we just hit it into can somebody change
what you find entertaining now when I
watch jeopardy I think of all people
microwaving TV dinners and sitting down
into a rocking chair sorry to show that
me and my dad bonded over and like it
was like the one crossword puzzles at
the same time kids and then just like or
and reading a book they're just
multitaskers and then once in a while
it's like who is John F Kennedy most of
ours about four answers that they even
have a shot at Good Shepherd
these people know like they got the
answers categories I think so cuz it's
so broad freakin random stuff you would
even have you ever got the final answer
I've never gotten the final answer I
don't get to that episode I don't get
that fun but the way that they do that
we're like they're reading something
they're too busy or whatever and then
they just throw out the right answer
without even [__] looking is like
Jordan going like that that's why we
like it it makes us feel so smart when
we get it right like though two times
you get it right it's like last night I
got Ming Dynasty right nice pretty my
wife was like really is like what do you
know about the meantime I don't know I
don't know where I put it from from a
file in your brain you're like trying to
make gave some the the dates and I was
like well Ming dynasty's all I know so
hopefully that's it no was that and
there was the writer that [__] is going
John F Kennedy and then he's immediately
like it is not John F Kennedy
[Laughter]
[Music]